the Mayan civilization is one of the
most long-lasting civilizations not just
in the ancient Americas but in the world
in general you can see the rough outline
here on this map of where the Mayan
civilization occurred you can see it has
the Yucatan Peninsula in the north the
Sierra Madre Mountains in the south and
it covers regions of modern-day
Southeast Mexico Guatemala Belize
Western Honduras and El Salvador we
believe that there were settlements in
this region as early as 2000 as early as
2000 BCE and then we have the emergence
of the first cities around 750 BCE and
even then there are signs of significant
cultural advancements there's evidence
that there was a sophisticated base 20
numeral system but included the use of
place value as early as 1000 BCE to put
that in context the hindu-arabic numeral
system which we now use in most of the
world now uses it wasn't devised we
don't believe until about a thousand
years later and it wasn't adopted in
Europe until about 2,000 years after the
time where we see the first evidence of
this Mayan numeral system this base 20
system that had place value now around
the 3rd century BCE so roughly in this
time period right over here we see the
first writing and these are examples of
what a Mayan glyph looks like so that is
a mine glyph and you read it in an order
like this and once again this is a very
early form of writing it's believed to
be the first form of writing
well-established writing in the Americas
now on top of their sophisticated
numeral system and the writing that they
developed they also had a very
sophisticated calendar their calendar
was more accurate than the Julian
calendar
was adopted by Julius Caesar and that
was the state of the art in the Western
world until the middle of the second
millennium so their calendar was more
accurate than what was used in most of
the world until around 15 or 1600 now as
we get into 250 in the Common Era that's
considered the Classical period that's
when some of the really great cities
start to emerge cities like Tikal and
calakmul and my opponent my my apologies
ahead of time for the pronunciation is
believed that at their peak these cities
had fifty to a hundred thousand people
now what we now believe is that it was
not one unified Empire that there wasn't
a Mayan Empire with a centralized
Emperor but rather it was closer to the
Greek city-states where each of these
cities were their own state they're more
powerful cities like to call or calakmul
might have had influence or sway over
others but it wasn't a unified Empire in
the sense of the Roman Empire or the
Persian Empire some of the early Indian
empires now it is believed that each of
these city-states they did have a king
who was not only a political ruler but
also a spiritual ruler considered a
divine king a connection between the
natural and the supernatural and we have
evidence that they practiced human
sacrifice as part of their belief system
as part of their rituals now near the
end of the fourth century there's
evidence that there was significant
influence or even conquering of some of
these cities by another civilization or
maybe we could say another city and that
is Teotihuacan we know that it was a
very powerful City and that in the
fourth century it started to really
exert significant influence and just to
get a sense of the sophistication of
what Mayan cities look like and I'll
show you what we believe Teotihuacan
look like in a second but this is a
construction of what to Kyle might have
looked like near its peak and Te'o -
Lakhan we have significant
ruins their tailor to lock in as you can
see is based near modern-day Mexico City
and these are the ruins from peyote
walkin and just to get a sense of how
sophisticated a city this was this is a
reconstruction of the map of the city so
the vantage point that you have from
this picture would have been roughly in
that area so what you're seeing right
over here are these these buildings or
these little squares here this pyramid
that you see out in the distance that
would have been this pyramid and so you
can see from this reconstruction of what
the city might have looked like it was a
vast and significant city pretty much
everything that you can see in this
picture was part of this great city and
it was believed that it was established
around 150 BCE based on our best
evidence today and lasted until about
the middle of the 6th century now the
name Taotao walken we don't that's not
its original name it's a name given to
it by the Aztecs but it's believed that
at its peak around 400 450 and remember
this is around the time that it was
exerting significant influence over the
mind it is believed that it had upwards
of a hundred thousand people living in
the city hundred thousand to two hundred
thousand I've even seen some accounts
saying two hundred fifty thousand people
which would have made it at the time one
of the largest cities in the world some
accounts have it ranked as the sixth
largest city in the world that we know
about now one interesting question was
was to you talk in an independent city
state by itself or was it the center of
an empire this is something that
historians debate today now some of the
evidence for why it was maybe a center
of an empire is it's believed it was a
multi-ethnic city we see its influence
over the Mayan cities especially over to
call as we get into the end of the
fourth century we also see this
incredible confluence of people and
culture and trade at tio2 Locken which
once again hints that it probably wasn't
a standalone city but it was probably
the center of some type of regional
influence or maybe an empire we don't
traditionally see cities of that size
form unless they're the center of a
larger Empire and they're able to get
tribute or taxation from other states
now Te'o - Lakhan ends up declining or
falling before the Mayan civilization if
you tailor to walk in in this blue green
line you see the Mayan civilization in
this light blue and then in the
Classical period this slightly darker
light blue and Teotihuacan collapses
around 550 in the Common Era and the
best theories we have today is that it
might have been some type of an internal
uprising maybe due to some type of
drought and famine and you can imagine
people will revolt if they're not able
to get enough food now the Mayan
civilization it is believed also started
to collapse a few hundred years after
that so as we get into the 800s the
Mayan civilization we believe might have
experienced some similar things maybe
some drought some famine that similarly
caused uprisings division and allowed
that to collapse now there are there is
evidence of some of these cities lasting
beyond the Classical period all the way
up until you have the European
colonization of the region and we'll
talk more about that and some of the
successor states like the Aztecs who
considered themselves a bit of a
successor state to the civilization or
to the city of Teotihuacan and we'll
look at that in future videos